Katheryn Winnick has become a breakout
star thanks to a betrayal of legendary
shieldmaiden lagertha in the hit series
Vikings but Vikings is far from the
first role winokur's nabbed in fact the
Canadian actress has been appearing on
film and in TV shows for the nearly two
decades here's a look at while Agatha
from Vikings looks so familiar Oh Canada
before making the jump to Hollywood
Winnick earned her stripes appearing in
a pair of TV shows north of the border
in 1999 she landed a screen debut as a
sorority girl Suzy in the paranormal
drama psy factor Chronicles of the
paranormal and later that year she
joined the cast of the high school
comedy student bodies where she played
Holly Benson girlfriend of main
character Cody Miller hey everyone has
to start somewhere
victimized starting in 2002 when it
began a long and lucrative psych career
as a professional victim on both the Law
& Order and CSI franchises all told
she's appeared once on Law & Order
twice on Law & Order criminal intent and
managed a CSI trifecta by appearing on
CSI Miami CSI New York and the original
CSI crime scene investigation over those
six appearances she's managed to do
everything from getting locked in a
basement by a psycho to being impaled on
a tree that is a tough way to make a
living Trump unauthorized back in 2005
Winnick played none other than Donald
Trump's first wife Ivana in a TV movie
called Trump unauthorized variety was
less than enthused about winix work
saying her accent sounded closer to
something from the Rocky and Bullwinkle
show than it did a Czech born Ivana
Trump the Donald himself gave his
approval however saying that having a
two hour movie on network television
while you're still living is sort of
wild he's supposed to be gone for that
to happen failure to launch when it got
a first big break with a minor role in
Matthew McConaughey's 2006 romantic
comedy failure to launch a film about a
man in his mid thirties who refuses to
leave the comfort of his mother's home
until he meets the right woman that
woman was played by Sarah Jessica Parker
not
but when he told showbiz monkey that she
would be happy to one day take on the
lead role saying she'd love to do a
romantic comedy a hundred percent you
know they're fun get me a good co-star
someone cute killers when it got to live
out the fantasy of every person who
bought a ticket to C 2010 hit man and
wife rom-com killers when she kicked
leading man Ashton Kutcher through a
glass door
most of winix other scenes as coaches
secretary Vivian were forgettable but
this one is notable for being the first
time we got to see the action chops that
would later make Winnick famous in
Vikings Love & Other Drugs killers
wasn't the only rom-com when it appeared
in during 2010 as she also had a role in
Love & Other Drugs where she got to make
out with Christina Fantino in front of
an awestruck Jake Gyllenhaal winix told
reporters that it wasn't just a cheap
stunt this movie is definitely for men
and women not only do you have that
sexiness throughout the movie but it
also it's a female character that girls
can aspire to be unfortunately the film
didn't take off and was another in a
string of duds for Winnick Barnes
Winnick met with bones produces in 2010
about the controversial recurring role
of Hannah Burley a journalist that FBI
agent Seeley Booth rescues from a
terrorist situation in Afghanistan they
warned her that fans might take a
disliking to her for coming between
Booth and Brennan they definitely want
the the two of them Brennan and Booth
together so I know I'm gonna be in some
hot water winix and on anyway for a
memorable arc that ended with her
turning down booths marriage proposal
allowing him to get back with Brennan
like the fans wanted for a bone what was
your favorite part of bones and bones of
obviously I've I see the bones stand up
guys
in the 2012 crime caper stand up guys
winning played a brothel worker named
Oksana though the film was a flop
the opportunity to work with some of the
favorite actors was a dream come true
for Winnick who told crave online I
really wanted to work with Al Pacino I'm
a huge fan
also loved Christopher Walken and Alan
Arkin I wanted to share the screen with
them and was excited just to be in the
same room as them the art of the steal
chances are you probably missed the 2014
ensemble comedy the art of the steel
which starred Kurt Russell as an art
thief and featured Winnick sporting
black hair this time around as his
girlfriend Lola Winnick probably wishes
she had missed it as well considering it
was a critical and box-office mess oh
well I can't win a mall Person of
Interest
the cult favorite CBS series Person of
Interest
got a visit from a person of particular
interest to Vikings fans when Winnick
guest-starred in 2015 she played Frankie
wells a bounty hunter relentlessly
stalking her brother's killer it's just
the kind of high-octane kick patrol
Winnick is perfect in our advice to
Winnick leave the lame rom-coms to
katherine heigl and stick to punching
people in the face it's what your fans
love thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
you
[Music]